[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies ladies and gentlemen the
president United States accompanied by
vice president resident United United
States
[Applause]
great to have you here
nice good so familiar basis so thank you
all very much and they've been treated
treated over the last long period of
time over the last few years
we're also using the module amazing
officers South Carolina get your share
again William Brown bro okay Palm Beach
County deputy sheriff in the same way
country small yourself or something
really really in particular 24 hours but
but our officers have been under vicious
assault hundreds of police have been
injured and even go down them an
invading army these radical radical
politicians 120 fund and abolish the
police
and I will increase in shootings and one
of the city voters and gonna cut it we
down but this pans around to know the
radical equality
when you play with my admirer in
straight rows Rosalia sci-fi crime is a
scourge this weekend guests guests 23
one to kill so seams are happening that
nobody's ever seen the scene happening
happened and city centres that are
liberally running around calling me : ik
radical lip and yet again ago in march
on area so what's happened but you're
not gonna happen having with me so
weasel first first when all of the
floors were doing doing things that
you'll be you'll be landing very
impressed with no person coming down
even we have to go and go where you have
to have 2020 keo keo 22 appeal with you
anyway we came shootings not even so
you'll see that's worse than afghanistan
this intersects worst worse than any
wars notice our it we're in by a lie a
lot makes them look like playing places
so the only control and we earned like
Billy we'll go around the room thank you
very much I think it's your Realtor
please
with the law-enforcement officer whose
lives in line impacted so profound
the courageous men and women in law
enforcement
[Music]
the police because we understand that
Walter is this the horsemen every day or
day best for special needs guns country
they risk their lives to make a dick of
difference communities and so thank you
thank you thank you thank you for this
conversation is the American people
equal greatly really benefited by being
vegan - Rob your questions long
philosophers you can mix each I
appreciate your shoulders to tell that
story
thank you thank you mr. president
[Music]
I've said poppy that to my mind there is
no more noble serving any kids
increasing risk of illness lessness
and a drug that reflecting casual castle
beyond anything that we've experienced
things that major more an increase you
name your name and who was expected to
deal with other other institutions and
pick up pick these pieces the police
will be sort and that's why that's why
they say Bob the jobless I asked him
today has never been every shower gel I
believe I believe it's important to
understand that just like just like you
know there's always always running for
and over the past several decades
there's one question in Police Lisa its
improvers and life like officer family
and we have the most obvious obviously
but the event in Minneapolis was gasps
gasps I haven't heard any morning
attempt to defend them and in peasant
has an urge to make short a continuous I
think I think law enforcement stands we
ease the concerns a community must be
its redress but we also and not for that
maybe and so since we actually actually
fun fun leaves or less or tricycle is
exactly the opposite is actually
actually we have we have we have to get
divorced or some more support more draw
training and resources I think they
think the executive order has an amazing
size last try strikes exactly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and as soon as edge there would be a
stop lady lady lady right there that was
like a grandmother and mother are you
still use that Monday so I don't go to
the vehicle and brand rant and say my
baby my baby she what
and you know utilize the breath that's
gone but as soon as the baby baby who is
now now
you
I was laying in bed with the only P so
again the police to be on the group did
a great job so Spencer has no sense of
danger so you say
mr. president almost everyone Arianna I
think it's really stayed with that dream
is not possible lon thank you so much
leadership everyone here today thank you
for coming what an honor it is to have
you here on this day thank you very much
what's more astonishing to me is that
we'll call Bill will call the president
will call leaders will Democrat Democrat
all that said you need hell no care of
they'll say no but you just had 40
people this weekend and they'll say no
no say no we're okay you just had 40 and
I'll say what's that all
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it wasn't for police officers because a
lot of times yes
I have the house I had full custody of
my son I worked for addiction recovery
care as a community liaison I'll see
other alcoholics and addicts addiction
recovery here as a providing supports
for those other elements and live in my
preference Fantasia thank you very much
it's a that's an equally incredible
statement you understand what you're
doing them so that's six years almost
city is looking coastal state level will
see you still celebrated in Kent okay
we'll see you in ten we'll see in
another four years
you
reaching through the shattered window
and checking for pulse and I was in and
out of consciousness and II
continuously Hirshman to stay awake and
stay with him very soothing very calm
and was calling on his radio for an
ambulance and first responders which his
being there sped up the process
dramatically he's the one who told me
we're gonna put a sheet over you to cut
you out of the vehicle
I move I was trapped in the vehicle and
also my injuries made me incapable of
movement he also followed the ambulance
to the hospital he gathered up all my
personal belongings that he could find
at the accident and brought them to my
husband at the hospital and explained to
him that I had regained consciousness
I'm stayed with my husband until the
tests were done and they said she's
going to be ok the most amazing thing to
me about this state trooper is that he
was off duty he didn't have to do any of
that
he was just happen to be at the scene of
the accident and immediately responded
and sped up my rescue and I'm eternally
grateful to him for doing that well
that's great thank you very much it's a
incredible story
so how seriously how long did it take to
recover how bad was it
I was I missed five weeks of work and
still have some injuries that'll never
go away but I'm very very thankful to be
here that's great job thank you very
much appreciate it thank you thank you
for being here please mr. president I'm
very clean pastor of Lighthouse Baptist
Church in Jonesboro Tennessee good in
our church watched over the last few
weeks as the way that our police
officers were treated all over the
country it was all over the news about
how they are such you know they've been
demonized and disgraced and dishonored
and we got our heads together and
thought what can we do as a small Church
in a small town to honor our police and
to let our voice be known their voice is
loud that blame all the
own police officers the voice of
small-town America seldom heard so we
just set up a little ceremony we went
through the Chief of Police and the
Public Safety Director and we asked them
if we could hold a public ceremony on
the steps of the courthouse on Main
Street in Jonesboro on July 4th at 11
o'clock in the morning and present each
member of the Jonesboro Police
Department with the check for $1,000 and
we did that and it shouldn't have but it
made national news I think small towns
all over America feel like we do that we
want our voice to be heard that we love
law-enforcement our local police
officers and if we can do something to
support them and encourage them and
that's what we want to do and we feel
very good about what we did well that's
a great story there you're gonna tell me
that they wanted to arrest you for
giving them a couple of bucks and they
deserve it very much but you know I've
I've heard the other end of those stores
also you're not allowed to do anything
and you're right about it they've been
what what the police have been going
through over the last number of years at
all fairness it's been starting and but
it's never been like this as it it's
never been like this it's it's crazy
it's crazy and they'll find out it'll go
the opposite direction unfortunately at
some point it'll go absolutely opposite
when they see and you're gonna have some
defunding and abolish again you'll see
numbers like nobody would ever believe
and they're gonna say let's get our
police back as soon as we can right but
that's great would you just that's a
fantastic thing yes so we were thankful
that it's a small town and a small
Police Department it was only 23
employees it wasn't that big it was a
blessing thanks a lot it's a good job
thank you very much mr. president I've
already heard no written to the church
that didn't identify the officer but
said I'm an 83 year old widower and one
of the officers brought by a sum of
money and gave to me to put back to pay
my utility bills this winter and told me
it was a gift
my house Baptist Church that's what one
officer is just a week ago but that's
what one officer did with that gift that
we catch back great stories thank you
very much appreciate Thank You mr.
president
mr. vice president for having us my name
is Debbie Wisner I'm local I live in
Maryland and my story's not very
dramatic it's just one that my purse was
stolen my purse people have it happen to
them my credit cards were canceled and
my cell phone we put a special note on
it that said if bound please call this
number nothing came of it
a couple nights later in the middle of
the night at midnight
the phone rings and a gentleman says I
found your phone I have your phone would
you offer a reward for it and I said of
course my husband said are you nuts
and he said I'll bring it to you
I gave him my address and hung up the
phone and call our Police Department
because that's who we turn to when
there's a situation my husband had
another idea he wanted to do something
else but I said no we're gonna let the
police do this there's no shooting
tonight so he the police came they gave
us their cell phone number they went
away around the corner and they said
when he pulls up give us a ring we'll be
there sure enough he pulled up he comes
out of the car it's two o'clock in the
morning now and the police two squad
cars were there immediately which is
what we need in our communities and they
checked him out he did in fact find the
phone and I gave him a reward and
thanked my police officers and I'm
grateful that we have community
policemen that are willing to come at
2:00 in the morning and do this silly
thing that's great thank you very much
thank you
2:00 in the morning why did he it's a
strange time so you found him to be okay
even though he came at 2:00 in the
morning he came in two in the morning
but so were our policemen yeah
that's the only reason we were okay with
it thank you very much thank you thank
you
really nice please mr. president thank
you so much as honored to be here I'd
like many others we support you in
supporting our law enforcement officers
and providing Safe Communities Thank You
mr. vice president for being here as
well and your hard work
obviously to the Attorney General
attorney general bar thank you and to
law enforcement officers that are here
and their families and to your staff mr.
president
although it shouldn't matter mr.
president I'm counting unique bird if
you will I'm a Democrat I'm an elected
official I'm african-american of eight
years or 12 years experience in the
Georgia House of Representatives eight
years as County exec and as County exec
I've had to manage a very large crime on
the largest police departments in the
state of Georgia but I've also had the
unfortunate experience of having to meet
with family members who lost a loved one
from a police shooting that was the very
probably most difficult part of my job
but I've also had a deal on the other
side where I lost two police officers in
one night
among several others I lost by lost two
in one night by the way they happened to
be in to have been african-american and
going to meet with their family members
as well as young wives with young babies
and having to experience seeing them
lose a loved one it's nothing anybody
would want to do but I can tell you this
mr. president by and large most law
enforcement officers those men and women
will honorably wear their uniforms each
and every day to go out when they're
running towards a situation others are
running from it so we have to stand with
them and I'll say this I have two words
we need more funding for police officers
not less funding and here's why I say
that when you look at law enforcement
and the equipment that's important for
them because it's protect and save their
lives as well as saving other's lives
but clearly more money is needed to
by less-lethal enforcement types of
tools like the bowler where they call
the bola wrap right we also need
resources for them officers usually
almost always only get the psychological
exam prior of being hired as part of the
examination getting hired
but afterwards they're not given those
type of psychological exams or
assessments and when you look at them
they've been on a let's say the beat
four or five years non-stop the number
of calls they're getting number of
situations that's the way we can detect
are they burnout do we need to put them
somewhere else that's important and
finally mr. president
Clemente but community policing is
important that relationship that trust
being fair
but enforcing the law and most people
including black people they want law
enforcement to be out there forcing the
law I think people just wanted to be
they want them to be fair they want them
to be swift in justice and we lost a
baby girl tube in Atlanta eight years
old and it wasn't to a police officer
more people have died from the protests
of black lives matter than prior to that
and so sometimes it's hypocrite because
almost as if some black lives matter but
all black lives should map and all lives
should matter so I thank you mr.
president for what you're doing can I
stay in solid with you thank you very
much good afternoon president Truong
vice president pence mr. Barr and
distinguished guests I thank you for
this opportunity to share our family's
story eight years ago our 15 year old
daughter was trafficked by ms-13 gang
members she was trafficked over a
year-and-a-half time period throughout
the DMV area law enforcement played a
fundamental role in the rescue and the
recovery of our daughter and we're also
vital in the protection and safety of
our family both then and now initially
the officers handling our case albeit
well-intentioned were not
trauma-informed and not able to
differentiate a runaway team
a victim of human trafficking once we
came in contact with trained personnel
former detective bill wolf our situation
improved we need to provide resources
and training to law enforcement to
properly address only not only the
offenders but also to the victims and to
their families because of mr. wolf's
expertise in this area we were able to
relocate our family to a safe location
we were able to get our daughter their
proper resources and help so that she
could heal and move on for her life the
law enforcement is crucial to the rescue
to the victims of human trafficking and
I believe we should support them with
everything we have thank you thank you
very much great story thank you thanks
so much mr. president for convening this
listening session and thank you for all
passion and you know being able to share
your stories here on national TV
president because it's really important
there's so many people who don't get a
chance to have their voice lifted and
having this opportunity to tell your
story to a president that's not only
gonna listen to it but take action is
extremely important to the work that we
do oh and I want you all to know that as
you go back home where we're still there
with you and we're willing to come and
do all we can to help create safer
communities since day one this
president's been really focused on that
and the unique way I've spent some time
on the road and what my colleague Scott
Turner trying to get local leadership to
work with us to not only change those
communities but empower people but
having these sessions here is extremely
important because most people don't know
some people don't know the pain that you
all go through and so having that story
be told on to millions of people is
extremely important but I think what's
most important is that we take this
session here and create action work
police department empower our Police
Department empower our families so that
we can change what's happened over the
last 20 years there's it's no reason for
places across the country in America to
have more deaths than a war over in Iraq
or Afghanistan you know that's that's
not the country that we're about and
this president won't stand for it and so
thank you so much for your president mr.
president for your leadership thank you
very much
you're doing a great job too I like it
so he a personal thank you officer Reese
here for saving my grandson I will never
forget it not always be grateful and I
would also like to add that I'm a state
employee I work in the city of Atlanta
and I have seen a drastic change and I
see the difference when law enforcement
is not visible on the streets so we've
had our challenges there and it's it's
peaceful now but when there is a lack of
law enforcement in within a community
civility brings down and crime increases
and I don't have any answers to any
solutions but I can just speak on the
fact that I have experienced it it over
the past three or four months and I
thank you for your invitation here and
for your time thank you very much I
appreciate it thank you first of all mr.
president vice-president Attorney
General thank you very much for inviting
me here today it's truly an honor to be
here i'm deputy corey reese with Palm
Beach County Sheriff's Office I have
been a deputy there for going on three
years now
last month in June
I was staying with my wife that a
Hampton Inn in Tampa off duty of course
work upon which guys' Tampa we were in
the room relaxing and I could hear a
lady in the hallway screaming for help
and so I went outside to see what was
going on and the young lady to my left
here was on the floor clutching the
child in her arms she was screaming for
help
the child was crying and there was a man
standing above them grabbing at her and
the child now my first thought was it
was a domestic situation but clearly
there was something going something
wasn't right with the situation so I
separated him and she said that she
doesn't know him and he was trying to
take her child and more and more people
came pouring out of their rooms and
we're saying the same thing so I
immediately got him separated I had him
sit down in the hallway and I had
someone else call a Tampa PD and they
arrived and at that point I just was
keeping the peace between everybody
because there were some people getting
quite aggressive you know with with him
you know it's not you know the right
time you know you have to let law
enforcement handle it you know it's not
a time to take matters in your own hands
so at that point it was mostly
peacekeeping but you know I I didn't
think it would be as as big of a deal as
it ended up being until you know the
next day some people in the hallway were
like the video has gone viral is like a
million views and and then I'm getting a
call saying I'm invited to the White
House I mean it just it was completely
unexpected you know I just just doing
what you know what I was trained to do
what I was told to do you know just
being there right time right place and
that's it again thank you for having me
here it's called natural instinct right
more than anything else thank you very
much
great job appreciate
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
when you've said it all so that's a case
that's still going down till then I see
beautiful guy too
beautiful okay that's just a few stories
of the thousands and thousands of
stories that we could tell and we'll
probably be doing this again but the
place they do it a great job they do a
fantastic job and they don't get the
kind of I will say this the people of
this country appreciate the police they
appreciate all they've done you don't
see that if you watch the news for the
most part you don't see things like this
but they've done a fantastic job
everybody here is a witness to that and
we see it a lot the Attorney General
sees it every day but we see it a lot
and I just want to thank the various
police departments law enforcement that
done an incredible job in this country
where they're allowed to do their work
they really do a job so thank you all
very much for being here good luck with
your case and really terrific job
everybody
terrific you thank you
[Applause]
well have a very good relationship with
doctor fetch I've had for a long time
right from the beginning I find it to be
a very nice person I don't always agree
whether my clothes the border as you
know to China clothes I did the ban on
China heavily infected and we saved tens
of thousands of lives and dr. Fox you
will admit that it was a good decision
it was very early that was in January
long before it was thought of as the
right thing to do I also close the
borders to Europe when Italy and a
couple of other countries over there
friends certainly Spain they were having
a lot of problems I closed the borders
very early shortly after I did with
China so we saved a lot of lives so we
made a lot of good decisions but no I
get along with him very well I like him
personally I can't hear you are you
going to pardon Michael Flynn well he's
got a case going on right now I think he
would I don't know those for a fact but
I think he's doing very well with
respect to his case I hope it's going to
be able to win it and I don't have a
decision to make until I find out what's
going to happen but I think he was
persecuted he didn't lie turned out he
didn't lie the FBI said he didn't lie I
think he was persecuted and nobody
understands what's going on with the
judge Justice Department which is so
capable they decided to take a view on
it and they they decided that he should
be they they were going to drop the case
so he's right now meaning his lawyers
and him are embroiled and hopefully the
final stages of what should have never
happened they treated him very unfairly
as they have many people on this side
yeah please the number of coronavirus
cases is going up because testing is
increasing right do you acknowledge that
it's going up for other reasons too for
example that it's at
ually spreading and what are you going
to do to stop the spread well you know
that we have one of the lowest mortality
rates anywhere if you know a Biden and
Obama stopped their testing they just
stopped it you probably know that I'm
sure you don't want to report it but
they stopped testing right in the middle
they just went no more testing and on a
much lesser problem than the problem
that we have obviously with respect to
this is the worst thing that's happened
since probably 1917 this is a very bad
all over the world's 188 countries right
now but no we are we test more than
anybody by far and when you test you
create cases so we've created cases I
can tell you some countries they test
when somebody walks into a hospital sick
or walks into maybe a doctor's office
but usually a hospital that's the
testing they do so they don't have cases
where as we do we have all of these
cases so you know it's a double-edged
sword at the same time we have the
lowest mortality or just about the
lowest mortality in the world we're
doing a great job we're doing very well
with vaccines and we're doing very very
well with therapeutics and I think we're
gonna have some very good information
coming out soon but we have the best and
certainly the biggest by far the biggest
testing program anywhere in the world if
you tested China or Russia or any of the
larger countries if you just tested
India as an example the way we test
you'd see numbers that would be very
surprising Brazil - you know Brazil is
going through a big problem but they
don't do testing like we do so we do the
testing and by doing the testing we have
tremendous numbers of cases if we didn't
do this as an example we've done 45
million tests if we did half that number
you'd have half the cases probably
around that number if we did it if we
did another half of that you'd have half
the numbers everywhere would be saying
oh we're doing so well on cases but when
I see it reported in the night you can
check me out of this I mean they always
talk about they're always talking about
cases the number of cases well it is a
big factor that we do we have a lot of
cases because we have a lot of testing
for
are more than any other country in the
world and it's also the best testing
yeah please potentially as soon as a
couple of hours from now are you
monitoring the last-minute appeals on
that case well anyone who is allow that
to be answered by our Attorney General
do you mind bill yes sir we we obviously
monitor the appellate process
consideration choosing your clemency
powers to stop these executions and
commute them to life sentences well I've
looked at it very strongly and in this
particular case I'm dealing with Bill
and all of the people at justice and
it's always tough you're talking about
the death penalty but when you talk
about people that did what this
particular person did that stuff also so
we're going to see what happens right
now they have a stay I believe right
they have a stay and we'll let the
courts determine the final outcome and
that's what's going to happen okay and
you're asking Americans to have full
faith in law enforcement
how do you respond to critics who say
you undermined your own federal law
enforcement agency the DOJ when you
commuted the sentence of Roger stone
well if you look back on it
this was an investigation that should
have never taken place you have guys
like Comey you have McCabe you have
struck you have his lover Lisa page you
have all of these people running around
you have Brennan and clapper who lied to
Congress you have many many people you
have people that change documents going
into the FISA courts and it's a terrible
thing and this is an investigation that
they said should have ended before it
started it shouldn't have started and if
it did it should have ended immediately
because they found as you know as well
as I do they found nothing
initially but it went on for two years
or longer and no I did I'm getting rave
reviews for what I did for Roger stone
and he frankly is going to go and now
appeal his case he had a jury forewoman
who hated Roger stone and who
hated probably me but she went in a
false pretense and he wasn't given a
fair trial he wasn't it's not a fair
trial wasn't given another try should
have been given another trial I won't
say more I won't talk about the judge
I'm not gonna why would I ever talk
about a judge but this was a judge that
gave I believe solitary confinement too
poor man afford Al Capone didn't have
solitary confinement so these are things
that happened and if you look at
President Bush President Clinton
President Obama take a look at what they
did frankly it's a very unfair Roger
stone was treated very unfairly in my
opinion and so were many others on this
side in the meantime you have the other
ones who are admitted lying before they
admitted they lied before Congress a
leaked they leaked classified
information which is something you just
can't do and what are they doing so
we'll see what happens but now we're
we're getting rave reviews for what I
did okay hold the convention in
Jacksonville with all this well we're
gonna see it built up a little bit but
we're going to do something that will be
great we think we're doing very well we
had some poll numbers a little while ago
that are great you know it's the same
story it's suppression polls that we had
in 2016 phony polls fake news phony
polls same thing and we're doing very
well we're doing well in Georgia we're
doing well in Texas I've read where I
was one point up in Texas I'm not one
point up in Texas where many points up I
saved the oil industry two months ago I
saved the oil industry there would have
been I created it we became number one
we have millions of jobs and we saved it
so Texas is not going to have to let go
of millions and millions of people
Oklahoma North Dakota many states we
have or $40 a barrel and yet you can buy
gasoline for under $2 nobody's ever seen
like that so we have the biggest energy
in the world when number one in oil is
you know oil and gas by far we're now
number one in the world and we would
have had millions of people out of work
I saved it and then they say I'm leading
by one point in Texas they said it last
time - they said Texas is too
was to call this was like three months
before the election
and then I won Texas and a blowout they
called it the minute the polls closed
they said that about Utah they said that
about men and Georgia they said the same
thing that Georgia's oh we can't fit
it's too close they'll never be able to
determine we'll have to wait till
election night on election night two
seconds after the poll close they call
Georgia so you know it's the same thing
we have the same thing they're phony
polls they're suppression polls but to
think that after saving the oil and gas
business and millions and millions of
jobs I'm leading Texas by one point I
don't think so phase one deal still
intact or is it do you think that's
intact it's intact but I'm I'm I think
what China has done to the world with
what took place they China plagued you
can go up the China virus you can call
it whatever you want to call it about
twenty different names what they did to
the world should not be forgotten but
it's intact they're buying whether they
buy or not that's up to them they're
buying they are delaying the opening
their schools New York already said they
were going to delay them other school
districts were giving parents the choice
whether to send their kids to school or
not what do you tell parents who look at
this who look at Arizona where a
schoolteacher recently died teaching
summer school parents who are worried
about the safety of their children and
yeah
school should be opened schools should
be opened those kids want to go to
school you're losing a lot of lives by
keeping things closed we did the right
thing we save millions of lives
we saved millions of lives well we did
the initial closure had we not done what
we did we would have had to - Mike and I
were talking about it before 2 to 3
million lives lost but we did that so
we're at about a hundred and thirty five
thousand and we'll be at somewhat higher
than that by the time it it ends and
again the vaccines are happening and the
therapeutics are happening but I'm not
even talking about that
so we'll be in a somewhat higher but we
would have lost two million three
million lives have we not done it now we
understand it also we understand there
were certain vulnerabilities young
children I was with talking to governor
Murphy and they have thousands of lives
I won't even say how many just thousands
of lives hard to believe in New Jersey
and he said there was only one life that
was 18 or younger one person died and
that was a person a young man that had
some medical difficulty so when you
think of that with thousands of lives
and you have one person that was under
18 that's something that tells you for
some reason I guess the immune system is
much stronger with young people than it
is for others so we have to watch the
group that does have the difficulty does
have the problem we all know what that
is we all know who they are especially
if they have a medical problem if they
have a medical problem diabetes or heart
or anything it's a it's a big problem
but we're being very careful but we have
to open the schools would you agree with
that do you agree you know we have to
open the schools we have to get them
open and I think there's a lot of
politics going along I think they think
they'll do better if they can keep the
schools closed in the election I don't
think it's going to help them frankly
but I think they feel that by keeping
schools closed that's a bad thing for
the country and therefore that's a good
thing for them but they're the ones who
city's burning I mean can you imagine if
the country was run like Chicago and
like New York and like some of these
other Democrat super radical left cities
are run you wouldn't have a country for
very long and the economy would crash so
we just set a brand new record today or
Nasdaq again this is now I think the
18th time since and this is since after
the problem so we have a new stock
market - a stack and the other ones are
getting very close when I came here the
stock market was up almost 500 points
today the economy is rebuilding jobs are
being produced at a record pace we've
never had a pace like this and I will
tell you if Biden got in this economy
would be destroyed you know your sin he
was in office for 48 years
and what he did was not great almost
every decision was the wrong decision
and now he's going to come in and try
and help us we didn't need any help
we built the greatest economy in history
greatest economy we've ever had the
greatest economy the world has ever seen
and then the plague came in from China
and we sort of-- we did the right thing
we had to close it down now we're
opening it up he can't do it he doesn't
have the capability to do it thank you
all very much I appreciate it thank you
good luck with everything
[Applause]